less than a month after 9 11 the united
states invaded afghanistan where al
qaeda planned the attacks the war lasted
nearly 20 years america's longest and it
took the lives of more than 2 200
american service members the united
states withdrew its final forces just
last month leading to chaos and the
retaking of afghanistan by the taliban
the islamic fundamentalist group that
gave al-qaeda safe harbor charlie dagda
is at pakistan's border with afghanistan
where people desperate to flee the
taliban are trying to cross charlie good
morning
good morning yes we witnessed some
heartbreaking scenes at the border
hundreds of afghans trying to get across
the taliban told us they're not stopping
anybody from leaving provided they have
the proper travel documentation of
course for the vast majority who want to
get out they do not it was a bit jarring
and surreal to see taliban flags flying
even now it was all very orderly we
asked the local taliban commander how it
was going he said since the americans
left life is fine and getting better
these female students at kabul
university may disagree whether an
actual support of the taliban or their
own self-interest they came to class
wearing full burkas adhering to strict
taliban rules even holding taliban flags
the u.n has raised the alarm on the
crackdown on demonstrations and reports
that journalists have been beaten by the
taliban now nearly 20 years after
america and its allies toppled the
taliban those hard-fought freedoms are
disappearing by the day
jeff
all right charlie dagetta who's been
covering the fallout from the 911
attacks for 20 years now charlie thank
you for your reporting